so you're only as weak as your
weakest link and that's why in this
video i'm going to be talking about
addressing
weak points and i don't mean
specifically weak muscles although
that's something i'd like to talk about
in future
rather i mean weak points within a given
muscle
because your muscle can be stronger at
some points in the range of motion
than in others and it's by plugging
these gaps that we can make ourselves
far more dynamic and powerful and gain
more control
over our strength and in particular i
want to talk about something called end
range strength which is a cool concept
that describes how much force you're
able to exert
when the muscle is in an elongated
position
so you might think that you know what
your one rep max is for a curl for a
bench press for a squat etc
but in truth you're probably only
actually using 100 effort in any given
muscle
at certain points during that range of
motion during the
trajectory that you carry the weight
through during that exercise
so a good example of this might be the
bicep curl that's a nice simple exercise
so right down at the bottom of the
movement your bicep actually gets
something of a break that's because the
weight is hanging and your joint
actually
takes a fair amount of that weight then
as you curl the weight upwards
you're changing the angle of resistance
so that the actual
involvement of different muscles is
changing once you get up to the top once
again you're able to support that weight
with your elbow joint and thereby you're
not using your bicep half as much as he
would be
at any other point during that motion
moreover if you're using a heavy weight
in particular
chances are you're kind of exploding at
the bottom of the movement
creating a sudden contraction which is
then propelling the weight upwards
meaning that
momentum is actually carrying the weight
through a certain portion of that
movement
this is what we call the strength curve
and thanks to the strength curve we can
develop these kinds of weak points if
you imagine that you're doing this
over and over again and you're kind of
skipping past certain points in that
movement
then it's easy to imagine that there
will be positions at which you
eventually
are not as strong as others this is why
if you're going to fail in a movement
you can get stuck in a certain position
maybe right at the bottom of the squat
or maybe
halfway through the bench press because
you're not used to exerting as much
strength
in that position this is where your
weakest and this is why training those
things and
fixing those weak points can make you
stronger and more controlled throughout
that entire movement
so that's the first thing we're going to
address how can we fix these kinds of
weaknesses well the first
most obvious thing you can do is to slow
the movement right down and use a
lighter weight
instead of trying to skip past the parts
that are difficult instead of ego
lifting
drop to a lower weight and really slow
down that movement not just through the
eccentric
but also through the concentric
[Music]
this is why i love quasi-isometric
exercises which are extremely slow
push-ups and pull-ups
you can likewise do the same thing with
really slow bicep curls using light
weights or
any other movement really using a light
weight
likewise you might want to train a
little bit more using things like cables
cables are different because the angle
of resistance
although different from what you'd use
with a dumbbell or a bench press can
often remain
the same so for example there are ways
to perform a bicep curl using cables
where the resistance is going to be the
same all the way through the movement or
even greater at the point where it's
usually
weaker so lower that weight and then
slowly move through those range of
motions
with the exact same amount of resistance
forcing your muscles to work hard
all the way through the exercise
similarly you can use bands bands don't
have the same resistance all the way
through but they have a changing
resistance
just want to point out at this juncture
that i'm not saying that using explosive
movements of very heavy weights
isn't a useful way to develop strength
i'm saying that you want both you want
that explosiveness
and that kind of slow control the other
point of a movement where we're often
weakest though
as i mentioned at the start of this
video is your end range the end range is
the point where the muscle is the most
elongated
it's at this point and also when it's at
the shortest that the muscle is the
weakest
this is actually one of the reasons that
we maintain a small amount of tension in
our muscles throughout the day called
tonus because if our muscles completely
relaxed and went completely
elongated then it would be much harder
for us to move explosively
when we suddenly need to but sometimes
you do need to be strong in those
elongated positions sometimes you find
yourself in a situation
hanging from a cliff this is something
again that happens to me all the time
hanging from a cliff or perhaps a
blocking a punch at a very unusual angle
where the ability to exert strength at
that strange position that elongated
awkward position comes in handy this is
why a lot of
calisthenics moves look so awesome like
the lalanne push-up
the leland push-up looks gravity-defying
because you need to
have a rigid torso throughout the
movement but also because you're
starting off in a position
that's often the end point for a lot of
other exercises with your arms stretched
out over your head so it's just this
uncomfortable strange position
and that's the first close to how we can
train our end range strength we do it
using exercises that put us in those
compromised positions those elongated
stretched out positions so the lamp
push-up is a great one but another good
example is anything that uses weight to
actually help us get into that position
which is a form of weighted stretching
tons of exercises do this for example a
weighted cossack squat forces you into
that deep side lunge which is excellent
for strengthening yourself
in that lower position then you've got
to get out of that position again same
thing goes for bulgarian split squats
and all kinds of other exercises a
number of
calisthenics movements also incorporate
a really good end range of motion that
goes beyond what you normally use
such as the v-sit which of course trains
that compressive strength
and a correction on my last video the
v-set builds up to
mana not maltese sorry that was just a
slip of the tongue and this will build
up more range of motion
likewise something like planche training
that has your
biceps in that locked out position and
challenges you to use instead your
scapula to push yourself a little bit
further this is the point where
the biceps and the apex pass the baton
over to the back and this is another way
to train that ranges of motion that
you're maybe not used to training
we can also take a lot of cues from
calisthenics and different forms of
mobility training
because endurance strength has a lot to
do with your mobility
so we tend to think of mobility as this
kind of plasticity this
stretchiness of our muscles and our
connective tissues but of course that's
not really
what's going on you don't get stretchier
as you practice stretching
what actually happens is it's more to do
with your nervous system your ability to
strengthen and contract the agonist
muscles the working muscles and to relax
the opposing antagonistic muscles
they're trying to push you
pull you back into that comfortable
position so as you try and reach that
uncomfortable position the muscles that
are working get weaker as they reach the
end range
of their strength meanwhile they have to
pull against the
antagonist muscles that are tightening
up and tensing thinking hey this isn't
right
and eventually that strength just isn't
there and you can't move any further
mobility is different from flexibility
flexibility is your ability to
pull yourself into a position or to use
an external object to get yourself in
that position
whereas mobility is your ability to get
there on your own so mobility is far
more useful
in martial arts in rock climbing parkour
and of course in any form of training
luckily there are lots of ways we can
increase the strength at the end range
whilst at the same time gaining that
control and that mobility
one example of this is something called
a passive end range
hold basically what this involves is
getting yourself into a stretch position
a passive stretch using some kind of
external tool whether that's a band
whether that's a bar or something and
then what you're going to do is going to
let go
and try and hold that position as best
as you can from your own steam
so you might not have been able to get
into that position on your own but now
you're going to try and hold that
position
and that's going to train yourself to be
able to do it again in future
it's essentially a form of overload
training another similar strategy is
something called a lift off get yourself
into a stretch position with your
shoulders
then you're going to gradually lift
yourself off and hold your arms in that
position can also practice
overcoming isometrics in these positions
so get into the position where you're
weak where you're elongated and then try
and push
against that position to go even further
using some kind of obstacle some kind of
object
to force against yourself so for example
you might lift your leg as high as you
can
put your hand on top of it then try and
push as hard as you can to go even
higher
this also shows you just how little
strength you have at that end range
now imagine if you were able to drive
more power into that position
how much more powerful your kicks might
be similarly try standing with your back
against the wall
lifting your arms overhead but then also
pushing your hands against the wall
to try and get them even further back a
tip when performing this
is to contract your abs and to move the
lower spine towards the floor or against
the wall and by doing this
you're preventing yourself from cheating
essentially by bending your back
instead of using that range of motion in
the shoulders eventually you gain
more strength and control in those end
ranges which not only
helps you to exert more power in unusual
positions
but at the same time helps to move more
freely and with less restriction
this can even help to reduce the risk of
injury because of course you're gaining
more control and more strength
right at the positions where you're the
most vulnerable another point is
when you're right at the top the apex of
the movement really
squeeze the working muscle that way you
are also
exerting a lot of strength during the
shortest most compressed position
that the muscle is in which is also an
area where we're normally very weak
of course make sure to ease yourself
into this kind of training gently don't
force yourself into positions that feel
very uncomfortable or painful
and at the same time make sure that
you're nice and warm before you start
getting into those positions
so there you go guys those are some
ideas and some strategies you can use to
strengthen your muscles at positions
where they're normally
the weakest let me know in the comments
down below if you found this useful and
what strategies you use
to increase your end range strength and
to address weak points in your range of
motion
if you found this video useful and
interesting then please leave a like and
share around that helps me out immensely
subscribe if you want to see more like
this
and if you like this kind of approach to
training where we look at things that
are
maybe overlooked by the mainstream and
focus on functional performance then
you'll probably like my ebook and
training program
super functional training i'll leave a
link to that in description down below
and this discount on whilst we're all in
lockdown
in that pdf ebook i go into a lot more
detail on a whole range of different
training strategies that a lot of people
just don't consider to try and develop a
kind of comprehensive approach to
strength
performance mobility endurance even
brain training
and then we tie it all up at the end
with a training program that you can use
at home and there are versions that
involve
little equipment for those who don't
have access to a gym right now
alternatively consider becoming a patron
if you do then you'll gain access to
some exclusive content as well as an
invitation to the secret bioneer club on
facebook where we discuss our training
strategies
share things we find on the web and
generally talk about human performance
it's a cool community and i really love
where it's headed so i'd love to see you
there
whatever the case thanks so much for
watching this one and i'll see you next
time bye for now
you